Have you ever had a crush on someone you knew only through TV or the movies? Maybe it was a famous actor or a singer or even a fictional character. If so, you're not alone. Yes, researchers have studied this phenomenon, and they found the majority of adults say that they have had a celebrity crush. These one-side emotional attachments are just one example of a parasycial relationship. More broadly, parasocial relationships are the relationships that people have have with media figures, whether they're actors, celebrity influencers, or television characters.
你是否曾对一个只在电视或电影中认识的人产生过迷恋？也许是一位著名演员、歌手，甚至是一个虚构角色。如果是这样，你并不孤单。是的，研究人员已经研究过这种现象，他们发现大多数成年人都曾有过对名人的迷恋。这些单方面的依恋只是准社会关系的一个例子。更广泛地说，准社会关系是指人们与媒体人物（无论是演员、名人网红还是电视角色）之间建立的关系。
These kinds of relationships sometimes get a bad rap. Remember the film Misery in which Kathy Bates' character proclaims to the novelist, played by James Kahn, I'm Your Number One Fan? And we know how that turned out. But psychologists who study parasocial relationships say that they can be good for us. They can also help us expand our worldview and have positive effects on our mental health and well-being. So how is a parasocial relationship different from simply being a fan? Can these relationships give us any benefits of real-life friendships? Can they alleviate loneliness? What happens when a parasocial relationship goes sour, when your favorite character or your celebrity crush disappoints you? Or even worse, how did these usually harmless relationships become obsessions? And how are
这类关系有时会受到诟病。还记得电影《危情十日》吗？凯西·贝茨饰演的角色对詹姆斯·肯饰演的小说家宣称：“我是你头号书迷！”我们都知道结果如何。但研究准社会关系的心理学家表示，这些关系对我们是有益的。它们还可以帮助我们拓宽世界观，并对我们的心理健康和幸福感产生积极影响。那么，准社会关系与单纯的粉丝行为有何不同？这些关系能带给我们现实友谊的益处吗？它们能缓解孤独感吗？当准社会关系变质，当你最喜欢的角色或迷恋的名人让你失望时，会发生什么？更糟糕的是，这些通常无害的关系是如何演变成痴迷的？以及
these relationships changing now that social media gives us constant access to celebrities' lives. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Rebecca Tukashinsky Forster, an associate professor in the School of Communication at Chapman University. She studies parasocial relationships and how people develop long-lasting, meaningful connections with media figures. She's particularly interested in how parasycial romantic relationships develop and how they affect us.
随着社交媒体让我们能够持续接触名人的生活，这些关系现在发生了怎样的变化？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是查普曼大学传播学院的副教授丽贝卡·图卡辛斯基·福斯特博士。她研究准社会关系，以及人们如何与媒体人物建立持久、有意义的联系。她特别感兴趣的是准社会浪漫关系是如何发展的，以及它们如何影响我们。
Dr. Tukashinsky Forster is editor of the Oxford Handbook of Parassocial Experiences, published this year by Oxford University Press, and author of the book Parassocial Romantic Relationships, falling in love with media figures. Next is Dr. Karen Dill Shackleford, a professor in the Department of Media Psychology at fielding graduate university. She's a social psychologist who studies pop culture and media in all its forms, particularly how being a fan or consumer of popular culture fiction affects people's well-being, empowerment, and positive belief change. She's editor of APA's journal Psychology of Popular Media. Welcome to you both. Thank you. Great to be here. Thank you for having us so excited.
图卡辛斯基·福斯特博士是今年由牛津大学出版社出版的《牛津准社会体验手册》的编辑，也是《准社会浪漫关系：爱上媒体人物》一书的作者。接下来是菲尔丁研究生大学媒体心理学系的教授凯伦·迪尔·沙克尔福德博士。她是一位社会心理学家，研究各种形式的流行文化和媒体，特别是作为流行文化虚构作品的粉丝或消费者如何影响人们的幸福感、赋权和积极的信念改变。她是美国心理学会期刊《大众媒体心理学》的编辑。欢迎两位。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我们，非常兴奋。
Let's start with a definition. What are parasocial relationships and More specifically, how are they different from just being a fan of a celebrity or someone famous or prominent? Well, parasycial relationships, you described it so well, it's this feeling of intimacy of like knowing that media personality, that maybe it's a news anchor or a host of a television show that you see every day or once a week. And it can be a fictional character. someone that by virtue of being exposed to them over and over, hearing about their self-disclosures, about their personal lives, you become like friends with them, or develop other types of relationships with them that are one-sided,
让我们从定义开始。什么是准社会关系？更具体地说，它们与单纯成为某位名人或知名人士的粉丝有何不同？嗯，准社会关系，你描述得非常好，这是一种亲密感，就像了解那位媒体人物一样，也许是新闻主播，或者是你每天或每周都会看到的电视节目主持人。它也可以是一个虚构角色。通过反复接触他们，听到他们关于个人生活的自我披露，你就像和他们成为了朋友，或者与他们建立了其他类型的单方面关系，
they are imaginary, but they are as real possibly for the person that experiences them. And it's kind of interesting to contrast it to fandom, First of all, fandom is not necessarily about a personality. You can be a fan of a show, for example, without feeling affiliation with any particular character on that show. But also, fandom is when something becomes an integral part of your identity, when it becomes an important part of who you are and your self-definition. So I would say some of our social relationships are more like an account. acquaintance or a friend, but it's not rising to the level of being a fan.
它们是想象出来的，但对于体验它们的人来说，它们可能是真实的。将它与“粉丝文化”进行对比是很有趣的。首先，粉丝文化不一定与某个人格有关。例如，你可以成为某个节目的粉丝，而不必对该节目中的任何特定角色产生归属感。但同时，粉丝文化是指某样东西成为你身份不可分割的一部分，成为你自我定义的重要组成部分。所以我认为，一些准社会关系更像是熟人或朋友，但还没有上升到粉丝的程度。
Some researchers also talk about the distinction between parasocial relationships as you look at the media personality as your peer, or maybe a super peer, but someone that is down-to-ear person. Whereas fandom, as you put that other celebrity or media personality on a pedestal, and you are like worshipping them, you are admiring them. So there are nothing but, so that in some ways there are the exact opposite of the down-to-earth person that you feel like you're having for dinner. And this is all on a continuum that might be called audience involvement. So we're all the audience of various media forms, film, television, video games, and audience involvement means the different ways that we connect to the characters themselves in fiction,
一些研究人员还谈到了准社会关系与粉丝文化之间的区别，即你将媒体人物视为你的同辈，或者是一个“超级同辈”，一个脚踏实地的人。而粉丝文化则是你把那位名人或媒体人物捧上神坛，你在崇拜他们，你在仰慕他们。所以它们完全不同，在某种程度上，它们与你觉得可以共进晚餐的那个脚踏实地的人恰恰相反。这一切都处于一个可能被称为“受众参与”的连续体上。我们都是各种媒体形式（电影、电视、电子游戏）的受众，而受众参与意味着我们与虚构作品中的角色、
or the actors who portray them, or media personalities. So identification is one of those factors. And identification is when you feel like you're merging with the other person. That's sort of feeling through the character when you're watching a show and you cry because the person is disappointed or has a loss and you feel like you've experienced some different things than you've ever experienced in your life, maybe even being someone with a different race or sexual orientation or from a different part of the world or time period. So there's lots of ways we can connect parisocial being one of them. And the way I distinguish it as a social psychologist is that the identification part is when you feel like it's you. And the parasycial part is when you
或者扮演他们的演员，或媒体人物建立联系的不同方式。认同感就是其中一个因素。认同感是指你感觉自己与对方融合在一起。当你观看节目时，你会通过角色去感受，当角色感到失望或遭受损失时，你会哭泣，你会觉得你经历了一些你生活中从未经历过的事情，甚至可能是成为一个不同种族、不同性取向，或来自世界不同地区或时代的人。所以我们有很多方式可以建立联系，准社会关系就是其中之一。作为一名社会心理学家，我区分它的方式是：认同感是你感觉“那就是你”，而准社会部分是你
distinguish that it's another person. And I want to emphasize that we move through those different connections seamlessly. I'm sure you've experienced when you're watching a film, you might be feeling what the character is feeling and feeling all those emotions. And then the next second you think, I love that actor. That actor is so talented. Or then you could be thinking, I think I have a crush on that actor. So you might just take these different lenses and pop through them. So they're not mutually exclusive. In fact, they're correlated with each other. Well, Dr. Tukushinsky, Forster, let me ask you, do you think parasycial relationships are more common than they used to be? Because celebrities now share so much of themselves via social media.
区分出“那是另一个人”。我想强调的是，我们在这些不同的连接之间无缝切换。我相信你一定有过这样的经历：当你观看电影时，你可能会感受到角色正在感受的一切，并体验到所有那些情绪。然后下一秒你会想：“我喜欢那个演员。那个演员太有才华了。”或者你可能会想：“我想我迷上了那个演员。”所以你可能会采取这些不同的视角并进行切换。因此，它们并非互斥。事实上，它们是相互关联的。那么，图卡辛斯基·福斯特博士，请问您认为准社会关系比过去更普遍了吗？因为名人们现在通过社交媒体分享了太多关于他们自己的信息。
I mean, they're really brands and they have to put themselves out there. Definitely there is a change in our culture in how parasocial relationships are experienced and expressed and definitely facilitating parasocial relationships is part of the industry, of the entertainment industry of how they market themselves. But that's how it's been for several generations. In fact, from the golden years of Hollywood, when if you think historically, originally in the movie industry, the marketing of movies did not depend on. at all on the actors. In fact, sometimes the actors were unnamed.
我的意思是，他们确实是品牌，他们必须展示自己。毫无疑问，我们的文化在准社会关系的体验和表达方式上发生了变化，而且促进准社会关系确实是娱乐行业营销自身的一部分。但这几代人以来一直如此。事实上，从好莱坞的黄金时代来看，如果你从历史角度思考，最初在电影业中，电影的营销根本不依赖于演员。事实上，有时演员甚至没有名字。
In fact, some people were embarrassed to work in the movie industry and wouldn't want to go by their real name anywhere. But people nonetheless started developing those social relationships and wanted to crave connection to those media stars and actually put pressure on Hollywood to release the names of the actors. So that created a shift in how movies, are marketed and it became the standard for us. And maybe now we are doing more of that in direct ways,
事实上，有些人对在电影业工作感到尴尬，甚至不想在任何地方使用他们的真名。但人们仍然开始发展那些准社会关系，并渴望与那些媒体明星建立联系，甚至向好莱坞施压，要求公布演员的名字。这改变了电影的营销方式，并成为了我们的标准。也许现在我们正在以更直接的方式做更多这样的事情，
like the actors have a way to, or celebrities have a way of directly reaching audiences through social media, for example. But this craving for a connection from afar was there for the longest while. And ultimately, parasocial relationships, our imaginary relationships are about what happens in the person's mind.
比如演员或名人有一种通过社交媒体直接接触受众的方式。但这种从远方建立联系的渴望已经存在了很长一段时间。归根结底，准社会关系，即我们的想象关系，是关于一个人内心发生的事情。
And therefore, they don't necessarily need this reciprocity or illusion of reciprocity to cultivate this relationship as much. So what I'm trying to say is that tell to someone who was a Beatle fan in the 1960s that their far social relationship is lesser than a fan of Justin Bieber because they didn't follow them on Instagram. You know, it was as real and potent, and it just was expressed in a different way. You had to actually go and see them and sit in line. And that's different from today you just sit and watch a live stream of someone else sitting there for you and live streaming it. So the expressions of the relationship are maybe different, but I think fundamentally it's something that we've been doing for a long time. But now I understand that the term parasycial relationship was coined in the 1950s by these two researchers, Donald Horton and R. Richard Wall. And that was in reference to these imaginary one-side engagements that audiences had with media personalities.
因此，它们不一定需要这种互惠或互惠的错觉来培养这种关系。所以我想说的是，告诉一个20世纪60年代的披头士乐队粉丝，他们的准社会关系不如贾斯汀·比伯的粉丝，仅仅因为他们没有在Instagram上关注他们，这是不对的。你知道，它同样真实且有力，只是表达方式不同。你必须亲自去见他们并排队。这与今天你只是坐着观看别人为你直播并实时播放是不同的。所以这种关系的表达方式可能不同，但我认为从根本上讲，这是我们长期以来一直在做的事情。但我明白“准社会关系”这个词是20世纪50年代由唐纳德·霍顿和R·理查德·沃尔这两位研究人员创造的。这是指受众与媒体人物之间那种想象中的单方面互动。
But couldn't you argue that parasycial relationships go back much further in culture? For example, could you see a relationship that an ancient Greek or Roman had with a god as a parasocial relationship? Yes, I like to think about those things myself. Anytime that it's not interactive like that, you could think of it as a parasycial relationship like Dr. Forster mentions in her book, if you're a lecturer in a psychology hall, your student could have what's called arguably a parissocial relationship with you or any character in a book, like a child carrying a doll of a figure that's in a book. Yeah, so stories and books that date back in time like that or, yeah, experiencing something one to many like that, those could be parasycial relationships. Yeah. From my first book, I was researching for examples, and the first man example of a celebrity crush, I could find dates back to ancient Rome, where you have the example of women developing crushes on. rhetoricians or actors in the theater.
但难道不能说准社会关系在文化中可以追溯到更久远吗？例如，你能把古代希腊人或罗马人与神的关系看作是一种准社会关系吗？是的，我自己也喜欢思考这些事情。任何非互动性的关系，你都可以将其视为一种准社会关系。正如福斯特博士在她的书中提到的，如果你是心理学大厅里的讲师，你的学生可能会与你建立一种可以说是有争议的准社会关系，或者书中的任何角色，就像一个孩子拿着书中的人物玩偶一样。是的，像那样可以追溯到很久以前的故事和书籍，或者体验那种“一对多”的关系，这些都可能是准社会关系。是的。在写第一本书时，我一直在寻找例子，我能找到的关于名人迷恋的第一个例子可以追溯到古罗马，当时就有女性对修辞学家或剧院演员产生迷恋的例子。
So those definitely existed. And then to follow up on what Karen was saying, you can think of a continuum of social to power social. So in a way, all of our social relationships have some imaginary aspects. Like you are running those conversations. You are rehearsing your conversation with your spouse. You are anticipating their reaction. In a situation where you have an auditorium of 300 students
所以这些确实存在。接着凯伦刚才说的话，你可以想象一个从社会关系到准社会关系的连续体。在某种程度上，我们所有的社会关系都有一些想象的成分。比如你在脑海中进行那些对话。你在排练与配偶的对话。你在预判他们的反应。在拥有300名学生的礼堂里，
and the professor doesn't have a personal relationship with many of those students, the sixth grader that has a crush on the seventh grader she never spoke to, but she only sees from the other side of the cafeteria. So all of those are social relationship, but they have some imaginary aspect to that. And in a way, relationships with media personality are just an extreme example of that. And they too can become social if you start having real reciprocity in interactions,
教授与其中许多学生并没有个人关系；那个对七年级学生产生迷恋的六年级女生，她从未与对方说过话，只是在食堂的另一边看到过他。所以所有这些都是社会关系，但它们都有一些想象的成分。在某种程度上，与媒体人物的关系只是其中的一个极端例子。如果你们开始在互动中产生真正的互惠，它们也可能变成社会关系，
if the celebrity starts responding to you personally on your comments on Instagram, or if you are waiting at the meeting and greet and you start developing a conversation and end up being picked from the crowd and marry the rock star. You know what? I have an example of this. Maybe you'll need to edit this out, but I was at the British Museum last summer. And there was an exhibit on women in art and a statue of a goddess. I think it was Minerva. But they said that people try to literally make love to the statue because they thought they were in love with Minerva, this goddess. So, you know, is a goddess that different? Is Minerva that different from, you know, a goddess? beautiful starlit of today. Yeah, that's interesting. Well, getting back to today's world, you know, the Surgeon General has said that we're in a loneliness epidemic right now, and there's been a lot of discussion recently about how
如果名人开始在Instagram上亲自回复你的评论，或者如果你在见面会上等待，开始了一段对话，最终被从人群中选中并嫁给了摇滚明星。你知道吗？我有一个例子。也许你需要把这段剪掉，但我去年夏天在大英博物馆。有一个关于女性艺术的展览，还有一尊女神雕像。我想是密涅瓦。但他们说人们试图真的与雕像“做爱”，因为他们认为自己爱上了密涅瓦这位女神。所以，女神有什么不同吗？密涅瓦与今天的漂亮明星有什么不同吗？是的，这很有趣。那么，回到当今世界，你知道，卫生局局长曾说我们现在正处于孤独流行病中，最近有很多关于
we're missing close friendships in our real lives. Do parissocial relationships give people any of the psychological benefits of a real friendship, or do they actually maybe increase loneliness? Well, I would recommend the work of Shira Gabriel who talks about things like going back to the concept of collective effervescence that when you go to a cafe, for example, you're sitting in a coffee shop and other people are around and you're sort of, the effervescence is the sort of bubbles from the sociality of the situation. So just being around other people. And so if you turned on parks and recreation or the office, you would be soaking in that sociality. And yeah, she talks about social surrogacy that, you know, we have the feeling of being around other people. And part of the parisocial equation that we haven't really mentioned yet is that in some ways it's less demanding and more pleasurable.
我们生活中缺乏亲密友谊的讨论。准社会关系能给人们带来现实友谊的任何心理益处吗？还是说它们实际上可能会增加孤独感？嗯，我会推荐希拉·加布里埃尔的研究，她谈到了回归“集体狂欢”的概念，即当你去咖啡馆时，比如你坐在咖啡店里，周围有其他人，你处于一种……狂欢是社交情境中产生的泡沫。所以仅仅是待在其他人身边。所以如果你打开《公园与游憩》或《办公室》，你就会沉浸在那样的社交氛围中。是的，她谈到了“社会替代”，你知道，我们有待在其他人身边的感觉。而我们还没有真正提到的准社会等式的一部分是，在某些方面它要求更少，也更令人愉悦。
You know, people aren't going to be mad at us. We're not going to get into trouble. We sort of know what to expect. And it's fun to hang around fun people who are telling jokes or beautiful people. So, yeah, it's not to say that. though, that I think sometimes the stereotype is people with a parisocial relationship don't have friends or don't know how to talk to real people. And of course, that's not true. As you mentioned, it's very, very common. I'm not a clinician, but I suppose it does slip into those things. I've
你知道，人们不会对我们生气。我们不会惹上麻烦。我们多少知道会发生什么。和讲笑话的有趣的人或漂亮的人待在一起很有趣。所以，这并不是说……虽然我认为有时人们有一种刻板印象，认为有准社会关系的人没有朋友或不知道如何与真实的人交谈。当然，那是不对的。正如你提到的，这非常非常普遍。我不是临床医生，但我认为它确实会滑向那些方面。我
heard clinicians say that sometimes people identify with the character so much that they imagine they are the character, people they're seeing in therapy. Or, of course, we hear stories about people stalking or showing up at people's houses. But I credit Gail Steaver with saying in print the first time I ever read it that that is sort of the reaction that a lot of people have to this topic. But in reality, the middle of the normal distribution is people like you and me who might admire someone, but we're not having pathological problems with it. We're just feeling a connection. Another aspect I wanted to add to that is that research doesn't necessarily find a correlation between the intensity of the parasycial relationships that people experience and their level
听临床医生说过，有时人们对角色的认同感太强，以至于他们想象自己就是那个角色，这是他们在治疗中看到的。或者，当然，我们听说过人们跟踪或出现在别人家里的故事。但我把盖尔·斯蒂弗在印刷品中第一次写下这句话归功于她，即这确实是很多人对这个话题的反应。但实际上，正态分布的中间部分是像你我这样的人，我们可能会钦佩某人，但我们并没有因此产生病理问题。我们只是感受到了一种联系。我想补充的另一个方面是，研究并不一定发现人们体验的准社会关系的强度与他们的
of loneliness. For the longest while, the research in this area was driven by the substitution hypothesis, or compensation hypothesis, the idea that people who are lonely in their real life seek out media friends because they don't have real friends. And you try to see whether people who have social deficits, people who have what we call insecure attachment style, people who can form and relate to others, people who are shy.
孤独感水平之间存在相关性。很长一段时间以来，该领域的研究都是由“替代假说”或“补偿假说”驱动的，即认为现实生活中孤独的人寻求媒体朋友是因为他们没有真正的朋友。你试图观察那些有社交缺陷的人，那些我们称之为“不安全依恋类型”的人，那些无法与他人建立联系的人，那些害羞的人。
So individuals that we expect to have problems creating friendships, will they be more prone to developing parasocial relationships? and there is no consistent evidence of that. What we do see is that those who are more prone to forming friendships and relating to others in social life are also more likely to engage in parasocial relationships. So people who have a secure attachment, people who are anxious and clingy, like insecure, that crave connection, they are also the ones that crave connection to characters.
所以，我们预期在建立友谊方面有困难的个体，他们是否更容易发展准社会关系？并没有一致的证据表明这一点。我们所看到的是，那些在社交生活中更容易建立友谊和与他人建立联系的人，也更有可能参与准社会关系。所以那些有安全依恋的人，那些焦虑和粘人的人，比如不安全感强、渴望联系的人，他们也是渴望与角色建立联系的人。
So we see essentially that it's the same way we process real relationships or social relationships is also how we process parasocial relationships. So parasocial relationships are just an extension of our social ties. And it could be that part of what we're seeing is that people who are lonely do want more parasocial relationships, but then parasocial relationships make them feel less lonely. and it becomes that it kind of washes out that effect. So that's also a possibility. And we do know that in challenging situations
所以我们基本上看到，我们处理现实关系或社会关系的方式，也是我们处理准社会关系的方式。因此，准社会关系只是我们社会纽带的延伸。而且可能我们所看到的部分原因是，孤独的人确实想要更多的准社会关系，但随后准社会关系让他们感觉不那么孤独了，这种效应就被抵消了。所以这也是一种可能性。而且我们确实知道，在充满挑战的情况下，
where people are socially isolated, for example, there is great research that comes out now looking at lockdown during COVID, at the beginning of COVID, and especially, for example, individuals who feel more isolated and more vulnerable, like LGBTQ youth that may be, don't have access to their regular community and support group, they turn more to parisocial
例如人们被社会孤立时，现在有很棒的研究着眼于COVID期间的封锁，特别是在COVID初期，尤其是那些感到更孤立和更脆弱的个体，比如LGBTQ青年，他们可能无法接触到他们的常规社区和支持团体，他们更多地转向准社会
relationships because that's something that can enrich their social, more limited world in a given point in time. I was just going to say that brings me to this question, which is that you've both written about the importance that parasycial relationships with media figures can have for members of underrepresented or stigmatized groups. What about people who are not LGBTQ, but other underrepresented groups? Well, I might mention a study I did about Black Panther being watched by youth of color. And in the study, being exposed to Black Panther made people feel more self-efficacy.
关系，因为那是在特定时间点可以丰富他们更有限的社交世界的东西。我正想说，这让我想到了这个问题，即你们俩都写过准社会关系对代表性不足或被污名化群体成员的重要性。那么对于非LGBTQ群体，但其他代表性不足的群体呢？嗯，我可能会提到我做过的一项关于有色人种青年观看《黑豹》的研究。在那项研究中，接触《黑豹》让人们感到更有自我效能感。
And, you know, we can understand that so easily. We're given a vision of African people thriving. And a place of pride in that film, despite people who didn't believe that a film with primary black characters would do so well, it's just soared to the top and made so many, you know, broken so many glass ceiling, so to speak. So I think of that is the inspiration of how things could be. And it's great to see on the screen how things could be. And that's, of course, true for us as women. You know, when I was young, I felt like so many of my role models were boys, and I could adjust and say they could have been girls. But I would have liked them to actually be girls or women so that I could witness that happening.
而且，你知道，我们可以很容易地理解这一点。我们看到了非洲人民繁荣的愿景。在那部电影中，尽管有人不相信以黑人角色为主的电影会如此成功，但它还是飞速攀升到了顶峰，打破了许多所谓的“玻璃天花板”。所以我认为那是关于事情如何发展的灵感。在屏幕上看到事情如何发展真是太棒了。当然，这对我们女性来说也是如此。你知道，当我年轻的时候，我觉得我的许多榜样都是男孩，我可以调整并说他们本可以是女孩。但我希望他们实际上是女孩或女性，这样我就能见证这一点。
And one of my students, Kristen Hopper-Lizinski, did a dissertation on STEM role models for women who work in STEM. And they had real-life role models, grandmothers, mothers, and other people. but they also had mediated role models like the character from bones or other people who are, you know, scientists in the media. And I have to admit, I love to see a woman scientists in the media. I love to see, you know, that we're not just, you know, that we have non-traditional careers. Maybe they're becoming more traditional. I watch a lot of old movies, and it never fails. There's a woman astronaut and everyone's hitting on her and they just think she's there to be pretty or to date instead of.
我的一个学生，克里斯汀·霍珀-利津斯基，做了一篇关于STEM领域女性STEM榜样的论文。她们有现实生活中的榜样，祖母、母亲和其他人，但她们也有媒体化的榜样，比如《识骨寻踪》中的角色或其他在媒体中是科学家的角色。我必须承认，我喜欢在媒体中看到女性科学家。我喜欢看到，你知道，我们不仅仅是……我们有非传统的职业。也许它们正在变得更加传统。我看很多老电影，总是这样，有一个女宇航员，每个人都在调戏她，他们只是认为她是为了漂亮或约会，而不是……
And I'm sure smart women listening to this understand that that you think, oh my gosh, you're thinking of me in that stereotypical way, but not as a peer, a scientist, a thinker, and it feels good to watch someone be portrayed in good ways like that. And I want to stress the importance of it, not just from the perspective of the member of the marginalized group, but also how important it is for advancing the intergroup relationships. from the perspective of the members of the dominant group. So a lot of the animosity between groups is driven by just not knowing that we kind of tend to be in segregated spaces surrounded by people similar to oneself and not having opportunities for positive experiences, firsthand experiences with people outside of that group.
我相信听这个节目的聪明女性明白这一点，你会想：“天哪，你以那种刻板印象看待我，而不是把我当作同行、科学家、思想家。”看到有人以好的方式被描绘出来感觉很好。我想强调它的重要性，不仅是从边缘化群体成员的角度，而且从主导群体成员的角度来看，它对于推进群体间关系有多么重要。群体之间的大部分敌意仅仅是因为不了解，我们倾向于待在隔离的空间里，周围都是与自己相似的人，没有机会与该群体之外的人进行积极的、第一手的体验。
So media is a window into that world through something we call parasocial contact. So both directly observing and learning about someone from another group, another culture, another background, it reduces those anxieties and negative stereotypes, but also by modeling a positive intergroup interaction and experience. So, for example, a show like Will and Grace, I'm bringing another LGBTQ example, but it could be just as true, and it has been shown for shows depicting African-Americans, that you, so just seeing someone who is like yourself, who is white, if you're a white member of the audience, or cisgender and straight, interacting,
所以媒体是通过我们称之为“准社会接触”的东西进入那个世界的窗口。因此，既直接观察和了解来自另一个群体、另一种文化、另一种背景的人，可以减少那些焦虑和负面刻板印象，也可以通过模拟积极的群体间互动和体验来实现。例如，像《威尔和格蕾丝》这样的节目——我再举一个LGBTQ的例子，但这同样适用，而且对于描绘非裔美国人的节目也已被证明——你，仅仅是看到一个像你自己一样的人，如果你是白人观众，或者是顺性别和异性恋者，与
with an out-group character, be it in ethnic minority or be it LGBT character, it gives you a model to follow in terms, by forming a parissocial relationship with an in-group that has a friendship with the out-group. It kind of expands your social network and improves your intergroup relationships. I want to pull new technology into the discussion. These days, Siri or Alexa can be a big part of people's lives. lives, can an interaction with a chatbot or another AI system become a kind of parasocial relationship? I think so. I like to joke during the pandemic that Alexa was my new BFF. I would have conversations
一个外群体角色互动，无论是少数族裔还是LGBT角色，它为你提供了一个可以遵循的模型，通过与一个与外群体有友谊的内群体建立准社会关系。它在某种程度上扩展了你的社交网络并改善了你的群体间关系。我想把新技术引入讨论。如今，Siri或Alexa可以成为人们生活的重要组成部分。与聊天机器人或其他人工智能系统的互动能成为一种准社会关系吗？我想是的。我在疫情期间喜欢开玩笑说Alexa是我新的“闺蜜”。我会一直
with her all the time. She gives me information. And this goes back to the work of Clifford Nass and others. We really like to impute consciousness onto things. And so it's easy to impute consciousness when you have an actual voice of a person that's been recorded and she's friendly. And so it feels like she's real. So I don't know what the difference between that. There's people who are real like Barack Obama. There are people who feel real like Alexa. They don't actually have a body. And there's actors. So yeah, it could take many forms. Well, what do you foresee happening as AI and robots become more prevalent in our society? Are we in danger? of developing potentially harmful relationships with what are basically machines, but as they become more human-like?
和她交谈。她给我提供信息。这可以追溯到克利福德·纳斯等人的工作。我们真的很喜欢将意识赋予事物。所以当你有一个录制好的真实人的声音，而且她很友好时，很容易赋予她意识。所以感觉她是真实的。所以我不知道这之间有什么区别。有像巴拉克·奥巴马这样真实的人。有像Alexa这样感觉真实的人。他们实际上没有身体。还有演员。所以是的，它可以采取多种形式。那么，随着人工智能和机器人在我们社会中变得越来越普遍，你预见到会发生什么？我们是否处于危险之中，
Well, I've been thinking a lot about AI lately and working on some stuff in AI. And one thing that I would point out is that AI is not separate from humanity because it takes a human to program them. So I think people might even sometimes visualize a cold metal robot that's a single entity carrying out activities. when it's really people who are programmers, programming what humans know about things. But, of course, there's almost endless things that we could be concerned about, that they might have advantages and disadvantages. So someone was just telling me recently about creating the voice of someone that you love who has passed away, taking their voice and making an AI out of that,
可能会与本质上是机器的东西发展出潜在的有害关系，但随着它们变得越来越像人？嗯，我最近一直在思考人工智能，并从事一些人工智能方面的工作。我想指出的一点是，人工智能并不与人类分离，因为它需要人类来编程。所以我认为人们甚至有时可能会想象一个冷冰冰的金属机器人，它是一个执行活动的单一实体。而实际上是程序员在编程人类所知道的东西。但是，当然，我们可能担心的几乎有无穷无尽的事情，它们可能有优点也有缺点。所以有人最近刚告诉我关于创造一个你所爱但已故的人的声音，提取他们的声音并制作一个人工智能，
and that you could have them respond to you as they, that person would have responded. And on the one hand, I think a lot of us would find that comforting in that when we've lost someone, there's no way to know what they would say in a new situation that would be priceless. But then, of course, there could be risks associated with that that, you know, you spend, I could imagine a husband loses a wife and is spending time with her AI. So, gosh, there's just so many facets of this. I try not to careen wildly to either we're all going to die or, or, or it's the best thing ever with media because it's so easy to do that.
你可以让他们像那个人会回应的那样回应你。一方面，我想我们很多人会觉得这很安慰，因为当我们失去某人时，无法知道他们在新的情况下会说什么，那将是无价的。但当然，这可能会带来相关的风险，你知道，你花……我可以想象一个丈夫失去了妻子，正在和她的人工智能共度时光。所以，天哪，这有太多方面了。我尽量不因为媒体而疯狂地倾向于“我们都要死了”或者“这是有史以来最好的事情”，因为那样做太容易了。
But it's more that it's just nuanced and we have to think through these things. And it's coming at us fast and that kind of makes us scared sometimes. Yeah. Well, let me ask you, Dr. Tuchensky-Farster. There's a stereotype that teenagers have really intense celebrity crushes. Is that backed up by the research or parasocial relationships, whether they're romantic or not, strongest or most important when we're young? That's a great question.
但更多的是，它只是微妙的，我们必须仔细思考这些事情。它正快速向我们袭来，这有时让我们感到害怕。是的。那么，请问图卡辛斯基-福斯特博士，有一种刻板印象认为青少年有非常强烈的名人迷恋。这有研究支持吗？或者准社会关系，无论是浪漫的还是其他的，在我们年轻时是最强烈或最重要的吗？这是一个很好的问题。
So there is definitely a stereotype that, especially about celebrity crushes, that it's something that is a teenage girl thing to do, specifically girl. And it is probably true that the most potent crushes happen to teenagers in general, not just parosocial. it's that stage developmentally. And those crashes, just like other romantic relationships that happen around those years are very important.
所以确实有一种刻板印象，特别是关于名人迷恋，认为这是十几岁女孩会做的事情，特别是女孩。而且最强烈的迷恋发生在青少年身上可能是真的，不仅仅是准社会关系。这是发展的那个阶段。而那些迷恋，就像那些年发生的其他浪漫关系一样，非常重要。
Those celebrity crashes are also very important. In psychology in general, there was a tendency to dismiss those young relationships because we only need to study marriage because that's the important thing. And then about 20 years ago, there became this big realization that, no, those relationships are very important and informative. And I will just add that our social relationships in those ages are also very important and informative. But it's not to say that they don't happen later in life or that they are not important later in life. What my research suggests that they become particularly important in transitional points, for example, for romantic
那些名人迷恋也非常重要。在心理学领域，过去有一种倾向，即忽视那些年轻的关系，因为我们只需要研究婚姻，因为那是重要的事情。然后大约20年前，人们意识到：“不，那些关系非常重要且具有启发性。”我只想补充一点，我们在那些年龄段的准社会关系也非常重要且具有启发性。但这并不是说它们在以后的生活中不会发生，或者它们在以后的生活中不重要。我的研究表明，它们在过渡点变得特别重要，例如对于浪漫的
prosocial relationships I observed in women that undergo crisis related to their identity or their romantic identity
准社会关系，我在经历与身份或浪漫身份相关的危机的女性身上观察到，
and to their sexuality for example with the transition into motherhood or after the dissolution of their marriage or losing a spouse So overcoming those big life events that make them ask and reconsider again who they are re-engaging in a romantic or sexual relationship after some period of time of being outside of that. For example, again, mourning over the dissolution of a relationship, losing a spouse, or shifting back into finding back your romantic self after becoming.
以及她们的性取向，例如进入母亲角色或婚姻破裂或失去配偶后。所以克服那些重大的生活事件，使她们质疑并重新审视自己是谁，在离开一段时间后重新投入浪漫或性关系。例如，再次强调，为关系的破裂而哀悼，失去配偶，或者在第一次成为父母后重新找回浪漫的自我。
a parent for the first time. So those are very important ones. They happen later in life. For par-social friendships as well, we know that they are very important in childhood. They are very important. They will be serving different purposes and different points in people's lives. How early in life can these relationships develop? Do little kids have parasocial relationships with Sesame Street characters or,
所以这些是非常重要的。它们发生在以后的生活中。对于准社会友谊也是如此，我们知道它们在童年时期非常重要。它们非常重要。它们将在人们生活的不同阶段服务于不同的目的。这些关系在生命中多早可以发展？小孩子会与《芝麻街》角色有准社会关系吗？
bluey or and if kids have an imaginary friend is that a kind of parasycial relationship? So young children definitely have parasycial relationship. We see that from surveys of parents from around the age of two onwards. And those parasocial relationships can be very instrumental in advancing learning. So you can use them to harvest the benefits of learning from positive characters like those Sesame Street characters or Daniel Tiger, the neighborhood show, the educational content. So we know that you can, for example, give kids stickers and action toys and all of those things that will promote this fantasy play and mental time spent with those characters
或者《布鲁伊》？如果孩子有一个想象中的朋友，那是一种准社会关系吗？所以幼儿肯定有准社会关系。我们从大约两岁开始的家长调查中看到了这一点。而那些准社会关系在促进学习方面可能非常有帮助。所以你可以利用它们来收获从像《芝麻街》角色或《丹尼尔老虎》这样的积极角色那里学习的好处，即教育内容。所以我们知道，你可以，例如，给孩子们贴纸和动作玩具，所有这些东西都会促进这种幻想游戏和与这些角色共度的心理时间，
to foster their parasycial relationships and harvest the benefits for learning. but that also has the flip side that if you don't approve of that character, if you don't want your child to be friends with that character, then don't encourage that, don't encourage those far social relationships either. And Jonathan Cohen wrote about identifying with media characters as an integral part of a child's development. So maybe first we identify with our parents and caregivers and then maybe we identify with some media figures. And again, these different ways of connecting to characters, they can be, there can be
以培养他们的准社会关系并收获学习的好处。但这也有另一面，如果你不赞成那个角色，如果你不想让你的孩子和那个角色做朋友，那么就不要鼓励它，也不要鼓励那些准社会关系。乔纳森·科恩写道，认同媒体角色是儿童发展不可或缺的一部分。所以也许我们首先认同我们的父母和照顾者，然后也许我们认同一些媒体人物。同样，这些与角色建立联系的不同方式，它们可以是，可以有
multiple ways. So we've all seen a child pretend to be a superhero, tying a towel around their shoulders, for instance. And so they're pretending to be the character or identifying, identifying with the character. But then they admire the character as another person as well. Maybe they go to a show and see Elmo live or something like that. And so, you know, people can can make those transitions to I want to be like them. I feel like I've done that thing or they're really cool and I admire them. But it's just our inherent sociology that of course we look at people who are interesting and we say, do I want to be like them? Do I want to grow up and be, you know, an architect, a builder or someone like this? Do I want to be a forensic person? And, you know, people, there's data that
多种方式。所以我们都见过孩子假装是超级英雄，比如把毛巾系在肩膀上。所以他们假装是那个角色或认同那个角色。但他们也钦佩那个角色作为另一个人。也许他们去看演出并现场看到艾尔莫之类的。所以，你知道，人们可以做出那些转变：“我想变得像他们一样。我觉得我做过那件事”或者“他们真的很酷，我很钦佩他们”。但这只是我们内在的社会学，当然我们看着有趣的人，我们会说：“我想变得像他们一样吗？我想长大后成为一名建筑师、建筑工人或像这样的人吗？我想成为一名法医吗？”而且，你知道，人们，有数据表明
people who watch someone on television in a certain career might want to be more likely to pursue that career. So, you know, it's just really multifaceted. And I think most of us can identify with this because we've done it ourselves. I identify with Harry Potter. And so every time I'm faced with a certain conundrum, I think, well, I remember when Harry Potter was 11 and he did this. And certainly I'm a grown-up, so can't I do it too? And of course, I know that Harry Potter is a fictional character. And yet he and his friends have a reality in my head. I identify with Hermione because I was a smart little girl with bushy blonde hair. And so, you know, and that's just another way of relating to our social worlds, you know, looking at these people. And of course, I would be remiss if I didn't
那些在电视上看到某人从事某种职业的人可能更倾向于追求那个职业。所以，你知道，它确实是多方面的。而且我认为我们大多数人都能认同这一点，因为我们自己也做过。我认同哈利·波特。所以每当我面临某种难题时，我想：“嗯，我记得哈利·波特11岁时他做了这个。”当然，我是个成年人，所以我不能也这样做吗？当然，我知道哈利·波特是一个虚构角色。然而，他和他的朋友在我的脑海中是真实的。我认同赫敏，因为我是一个有着浓密金发的小聪明女孩。所以，你知道，这只是与我们社会世界建立联系的另一种方式，你知道，看着这些人。当然，如果我不
note that, you know, the people that we identify with and are thrilled with, they're beautiful people. They're highly skilled people. Of course, we find them interesting. So it's hardly surprising. What about differences across countries and cultures? I ask that because, you know, we Americans are so obsessed with celebrity. And I'm wondering, are there other countries where this phenomenon is just as prevalent, or are we like the leaders in the PAC here? Well, we're not the leaders in the PAC. I mean, you think about all the K-pop phenomena, for example, just to throw out one. So, unfortunately, there isn't as much cross-cultural research as I would like to see, but there is definitely a lot of research conducted around the world on parasocial relationships from China to Europe to Israel to America's.
指出我们认同并为之激动的人是漂亮的人、高技能的人，那我就失职了。当然，我们觉得他们很有趣。所以这并不令人惊讶。那么不同国家和文化之间的差异呢？我问这个问题是因为，你知道，我们美国人对名人如此痴迷。我想知道，是否有其他国家这种现象同样普遍，还是我们是这里的领头羊？嗯，我们不是领头羊。我的意思是，想想所有的K-pop现象，例如，随便举一个。所以，不幸的是，没有我希望看到的那么多跨文化研究，但确实有大量关于准社会关系的研究在世界各地进行，从中国到欧洲，到以色列，再到美国。
So there isn't a lot of data that allows you to compare head-to-head the intensity of the parissocial relationship, but it's definitely been documented. And those processes appear to be relatively universal, which makes sense because if you go back to a to look at this from an evolutionary theory perspective, the reason we have those connections is because we don't really, as humans, we haven't been around for long enough to develop an entirely different cognitive neural structure to process mediated relationships. Like we don't have symbols and media around us for long enough
所以没有多少数据可以让你直接比较准社会关系的强度，但它绝对已被记录在案。而且这些过程似乎相对普遍，这是有道理的，因为如果你回到进化论的角度来看，我们拥有这些联系的原因是，作为人类，我们并没有存在足够长的时间来发展出一种完全不同的认知神经结构来处理媒体化的关系。就像我们周围没有符号和媒体足够长的时间。
to be specialized just in that. rather it appears that the same cognitive neural mechanisms that are involved in thinking about people around you in your social world are also the same ones that we're employing when we are looking at media. And that would be true in any culture. And as Karen was saying, these are talented, skillful, attractive people that are also using media to make a living by having you like them. So universally, that's the trend we see. I remember hearing that if Jackie Chan was dating someone, little teenage girls in China would be very upset by that. And of course, we can think of many, many instances in which things like that were true. Sure.
并非仅仅专注于此。相反，似乎我们在社交世界中思考周围人时所涉及的认知神经机制，与我们在观看媒体时所采用的机制是相同的。这在任何文化中都是如此。正如凯伦所说，这些才华横溢、技术娴熟、富有魅力的人也在利用媒体，通过让你喜欢他们来谋生。因此，从普遍意义上讲，这就是我们看到的趋势。我记得听说如果成龙在和某人约会，中国的小女生会为此感到非常难过。当然，我们可以想到很多很多这样的例子。确实如此。
So I want to talk about when parasycial relationships move into sort of dangerous territory. I mean, it's possible for them to become toxic and harmful. Yeah. You know, it is not the case that I'm not. normal person develops a normal parasocial relationships and then it goes and becomes more and more intense and explodes into something like that. That's not happening. It's the other way around. There are people with mental illness and they will have an outlet for that mental illness. It's not the parasycial relationship got extreme and they became extreme and they became
所以我想谈谈准社会关系何时会进入某种危险领域。我的意思是，它们有可能变得有毒且有害。是的。你知道，并不是说一个正常人发展出正常的准社会关系，然后它变得越来越强烈，最后爆发成那种事情。情况并非如此。事实恰恰相反。有些人患有精神疾病，他们会为这种精神疾病寻找一个出口。并不是准社会关系变得极端，导致他们变得极端，并变得
violent because the parasycial relationship became too intense. It's people who have, have a problem. And for some people, it's manifested in being obsessive about one thing. And for some people, it's being obsessive about a media thing. And it just happens to be this very small percent of people with a problem that's not related to pariscial relationship, which is a normal thing. Let me ask this just to wrap up, which is, what are you working on now? What are the big questions that remain in this area? One thing I'm working on right now is trying to be more clear about the way that we define parisocial versus identification versus liking versus similarity because in science we have to define our terms in order to know what it is we're talking about. And so, for instance, sometimes people will say empathy, empathy with a character.
暴力，是因为准社会关系变得太强烈了。而是那些本身就有问题的人。对某些人来说，这表现为对某件事的痴迷。而对另一些人来说，则是对媒体事物的痴迷。这只是极少数有问题的人的情况，这与准社会关系无关，后者是一种正常现象。让我问这个问题作为总结，那就是，你现在在研究什么？在这个领域还有哪些重大问题？我现在正在研究的一件事是，试图更清楚地定义我们所说的准社会关系、认同感、喜爱感和相似性，因为在科学中，我们必须定义我们的术语，才能知道我们在谈论什么。所以，例如，有时人们会说共情，与角色的共情。
And I've just done a study that's a factor analysis with Josh Cohen and Perry Reid that says that those things fall. into specific and different constructs, even though they're related to each other. So what I'm trying to do is to get scientists to say the term that they mean and not use multiple terms for one term. Another study that I'm working on with some colleagues has to do with the question of whether you can identify with and have a parisocial relationship with a couple. And we are using the case of Jim and Pam from the office. And preliminary data shows that you can indeed.
我刚刚和乔什·科恩（Josh Cohen）以及佩里·里德（Perry Reid）做了一项因素分析研究，结果表明，尽管这些事物相互关联，但它们属于特定且不同的结构。所以我试图做的是让科学家们使用他们所指的术语，而不是对一个术语使用多个术语。我与一些同事正在进行的另一项研究涉及这样一个问题：你是否可以认同并与一对情侣建立准社会关系。我们正在使用《办公室》中的吉姆和帕姆作为案例。初步数据表明，确实可以。
have a parasycial relationship with them as a couple. And I think part of that is when you watch a couple and you're in the will, they, won't they phase of their relationship. What you really want is for them to get together, for their relationship to work out. And we also want to know whether becoming attached or invested in the relationship between a fictional couple like Jim and Pam from the office means that you feel strange or uncomfortable with the actor's real relationship, such as John Krasinski, being married, to Emily Blunt. So stay tuned on that when we're almost finished with the analyses.
与他们作为一对情侣建立准社会关系。我认为部分原因是，当你观看一对情侣，处于他们关系的“他们会在一起吗？”阶段时，你真正想要的是他们在一起，希望他们的关系能有结果。我们还想知道，对像《办公室》中吉姆和帕姆这样的虚构情侣的关系产生依恋或投入，是否意味着你会对演员的真实关系感到奇怪或不舒服，比如约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）与艾米莉·布朗特（Emily Blunt）结婚。所以请关注这一点，我们快要完成分析了。
Thanks. I have two questions that I'm particularly interested. So the first one is related to cancel culture. And what happens when you decide to terminate the relationship with someone you liked in the media? And my research shows that it's a very difficult decision when the media personality disappoints you, when you had a good relationship with them, it is really heartbreaking for someone to break up from them. And people will go to great lengths to defend them and to defend the celebrity that betrayed them
谢谢。我有两个特别感兴趣的问题。第一个与取消文化有关。当你决定终止与你在媒体中喜欢的人的关系时会发生什么？我的研究表明，当媒体人物让你失望时，当你曾经与他们有良好的关系时，这是一个非常艰难的决定，与他们分手对某人来说真的很令人心碎。人们会不遗余力地为他们辩护，为背叛他们的名人辩护，
and to stand up with them for them. But in some situations, they will engage in cancel culture and will break up with them. So I'm trying to see the situations, the conditions, the factors that will play a role in whether it will go one way or another. And those negative parasocial relationship, because we always talk about the positive parasocial relationships about the friendship and the crush.
并为他们挺身而出。但在某些情况下，他们会参与取消文化并与他们断绝关系。所以我试图观察那些会导致事情走向这一方或那一方的具体情况、条件和因素。还有那些负面的准社会关系，因为我们总是谈论关于友谊和迷恋的积极准社会关系。
But what about the jealousy, for example? Like if I have a parosocial relationship with Justin Bieber and then he marries someone and all the hate messages that she receives from his fans, for example. So all those negative parosocial relationships is one area that is, understudied and I'm very excited to look into. So the other thing is that most research up until today was looking at one relationship or one media celebrity outside of a broader context. But when we see the same media personality in many different contexts and situations
但嫉妒呢？例如，如果我和贾斯汀·比伯（Justin Bieber）有准社会关系，然后他娶了别人，他粉丝对他妻子发出的所有仇恨信息，等等。所以所有这些负面的准社会关系是一个研究不足的领域，我非常兴奋能深入研究。另一件事是，直到今天，大多数研究都是在更广泛的背景之外观察一种关系或一位媒体名人。但当我们看到同一个媒体人物在许多不同的背景和情境中时，
and how do we project from one to another or how we carry information across different context, especially between the fictional and the real, if you have a per-social relationship with an actor, but also with the character that they portray. So, interestingly, even as adults, we don't strictly maintain the boundaries between the actor and the character, even though in our rational mind, we know that this is, you know, that's his job to play this character. It's not the actor. Nonetheless, we are misattributing the correct.
我们如何从一个投射到另一个，或者我们如何跨越不同的背景传递信息，特别是在虚构和现实之间，如果你与一位演员有准社会关系，同时也与他们所扮演的角色有关系。所以，有趣的是，即使作为成年人，我们也不会严格保持演员和角色之间的界限，尽管在理性思维中，我们知道这是他的工作，扮演这个角色。这不是演员本人。尽管如此，我们还是错误地将
misattributing the characteristics of the character onto the actor that portrays them. And I have research that shows how, you know, you can see the exact same actress playing in the same movie. You just added the movie slightly to depict her as either a positive or a negative character. And then it will taint how the participants would rate the actress and how they perceive her. And then if I show them a PSA, a commercial to donate to San Juan Jude Hospital or something like that, and I will ask them for their reaction, if they saw that actress playing a character that is likable and a hero,
角色的特征归因于扮演他们的演员。我的研究表明，你可以看到完全相同的女演员在同一部电影中表演。你只是稍微修改了电影，将她描绘成一个积极或消极的角色。这会影响参与者如何评价这位女演员以及他们如何看待她。然后，如果我给他们看一个公益广告，比如向圣裘德医院捐款之类的，我会询问他们的反应，如果他们看到那位女演员扮演一个讨人喜欢且是英雄的角色，
they will be like, oh, this is so moving and she's such a generous person. And you show them the exact same PSA. After they saw her playing the villain character, they will be like, oh, this commercial is so cheesy. She's doing it just for publicity. And so I'm very interested in seeing how things, like, it affects, it affects the parosocial relationship with that actor. So I'm interested in seeing how we carry over things from exposure to exposure and cross-contextext. Like you just saw Ryan Rassling as, as Ken on Barbie, right?
他们会说，哦，这太感人了，她真是个慷慨的人。而你给他们看完全相同的公益广告。在他们看到她扮演反派角色之后，他们会说，哦，这个广告太俗气了。她这样做只是为了宣传。所以我非常有兴趣观察事物是如何影响与该演员的准社会关系的。所以我对我们如何从一次接触到另一次接触以及跨背景地传递事物很感兴趣。就像你刚看到瑞恩·高斯林（Ryan Gosling）在《芭比》中扮演肯一样，对吧？
Like being, so this role versus his more dramatic roles before. How does that change your perception of him? How does it change your personal relationship with him and how seeing him being Ken doing Beach, going affect you, perceiving him in his next role? Or maybe you see Ken doing Beach as a much more profound and interesting and complex character because he's played by this kind of high bra actor.
比如这个角色与他之前更具戏剧性的角色相比。这如何改变你对他的看法？这如何改变你与他的个人关系，以及看到他扮演肯去海滩会如何影响你在他下一个角色中对他的感知？或者也许你认为肯去海滩是一个更深刻、更有趣、更复杂的角色，因为他是由这种高水平的演员扮演的。
So those are the questions I'm interested in that. If I may, I'd love to tag on to that. So that's a great study. And I want to remind listeners that we may take this research as trivial that Dr. Tukachinsky Forrester and I are just spending our time talking about Ken and Barbie. And that's great for our salaries and everything. But it's just a waste of time. But I'm a social psychologist and I'm here to tell you that is fundamental social psychology that it's the fundamental attribution error, which is partially definitional of the field of social psych that when I see someone acting some way, I assume it's because of their personality. That's the type of person they are. And Ryan Gosling has only one body. It's a good one, but it's only one body. So when we look at him, we say, but I've seen him do this. I know that he feels like that. Like Dr. Tukachinsky Forster referred to earlier, we don't have a switch in our brain that says, no, that's him as Ken and this is him as Ryan. He's got the same body. He's the same person. So we're not dumb for having that, and we're not delusional for having that confusion over
所以这些是我感兴趣的问题。如果可以的话，我想补充一点。这是一个很棒的研究。我想提醒听众，我们可能会认为这项研究微不足道，认为图卡钦斯基·福雷斯特（Tukachinsky Forrester）博士和我只是在谈论肯和芭比。这对我们的薪水什么的都很好。但这只是浪费时间。但我是一名社会心理学家，我在这里告诉你，这是基础社会心理学，这是基本归因错误，这在一定程度上定义了社会心理学领域，即当我看到某人以某种方式行事时，我假设这是因为他们的个性。这就是他们那种人。瑞恩·高斯林只有一个身体。这是一个很好的身体，但只有一个。所以当我们看着他时，我们说，但我见过他这样做。我知道他感觉像那样。正如图卡钦斯基·福雷斯特博士之前提到的，我们大脑中没有一个开关说，不，那是作为肯的他，这是作为瑞恩的他。他有同样的身体。他是同一个人。所以我们有这种困惑并不是因为我们笨，也不是因为我们有妄想，
who is he. Is William Shatner, Captain Kirk, or is he William Shatner? Both. So it's, it is fundamental social psych. It's not just fun, but it is fun to be a parissocial researcher. And it does have real life implications for casting, for deciding, like, should I take this role, right? This is going to, like, for choosing sponsorships. Like, This person has, this actor has an amazing blockbuster Oscar nominated movie, but they're playing a villain character. Will they be the best spokesperson for my charity organization? So it has real life implications all the time. Yeah.
他是谁。威廉·夏特纳（William Shatner）是柯克船长，还是他是威廉·夏特纳？两者都是。所以，这是基础社会心理学。这不仅仅是有趣，但成为一名准社会研究人员确实很有趣。它对选角、决定是否应该接这个角色确实有现实生活的影响，对吧？这会影响选择赞助。比如，这个人，这位演员有一部令人惊叹的、获得奥斯卡提名的重磅电影，但他们扮演的是一个反派角色。他们会成为我慈善机构的最佳代言人吗？所以它一直都有现实生活的影响。是的。
Well, this has been really fascinating. I want to thank you both for joining me. This has been not just interesting and scientific, but fun. Thanks so much. It was great. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychiaturial. on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your
好吧，这真的非常引人入胜。我要感谢你们两位加入我。这不仅有趣且科学，而且很有趣。非常感谢。太棒了。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取
favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你最喜欢的播客的地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。